por fin están en sus manos las visas
fueron entregadas por la secretaria de
asuntos exteriores de mexico
estas cinco jóvenes afganas fueron
acogidas por mexico hacen parte de un
equipo internacional de 20 ingenieros
aprendices de robótica decidieron salir
de afganistán después de que los
talibanes tomaran el poder con el pesar
de dejar sus estudios es un honor poder
estar aquí a salvo gracias por salvarnos
la vida al otro lado del planeta dos
días antes otra parte del grupo aterrizó
en doha qatar mismo curso mismas
esperanzas y la misma decisión con el
corazón en la garganta
héctor family dejamos a nuestras
familias
lo siento
es muy duro porque se quedaron ahí
porque nuestro país está destruyendo tan
conocidas como las soñadoras afganas
estas jóvenes entre las cuales hay
varias adolescentes ganaron un premio
internacional de ingeniería robótica
imaginaron un nuevo ventilador para
pacientes de covite hecho a partir de
piezas de automóviles viejos